be a good listener sit quietly and wait
your turn to talk right not in Japan
here it's actually rude not to interrupt
someone and here's why
welcome to my old dojo I practiced a
martial art called Kindle the sword path
while we drilled our way through
footwork and each cut of the sword over
and over my highest-ranked sensei
watched with intent eyes and a jolly
smile but he wouldn't wait to grade us
on our skills feedback was constant
always talking always mm Sol's
also every step every move of the hand
right or wrong there was almost a rhythm
to it a rhythm with a constant flow of
interjections looking back I think what
was going on here was a kind of izu Chi
consider a conversation in English the
person who's talking shares a thought
and you listen quietly until they finish
no actually that may be polite for some
but for most of us there's more back and
forth with room for reactions
transitions and taking turns but that's
important
no cuts wait your turn now a
conversation in Japanese notice all the
interaction by the listener the speaker
barely gets out the topic before they're
cut off then come huh and yes isn't
really scattered throughout clearly
Japan has a different opinion on what
being a good listener means to see why
think back to Kindle not Kindle with my
sensei but 550 years ago when a struggle
for Shogunate succession broke out into
the intense only mode on warriors
trained to take up the sword and iron
workers to produce them as swordsmith
and apprenticed hammered together back
and forth they coined a new term IDEs
achieve mutual Mallett later this
compound became a metaphor for Japan's
culturally valued take on being a good
listener
today chiming in is still either jutsu
to strike mutual mallets
this involves talking back with a bunch
of tokens little words of phrases your
choice of tokens varies but most get
reused frequently and not only when it's
your turn more often than not and for
some by definition you say these tokens
when the speaker is still talking it's
happening at the same time overlapping
the speaker's speech but Isaac is not
merely a list of memorized key words
Japanese listeners pay attention even
repeating or asking for more so last
month last month yes I was visiting
family family really master this because
bad izg can get you labeled or a cold
shallow I first learned about
ironworkers and mutual Malik's from this
master's thesis the same anthropologists
later did a study on conversations
between u.s. and japanese businesspeople
she acknowledges the Japanese stereotype
that America gene are dry but then
introduces someone who is never called
cold Gary here is Gary helping a
co-worker with an English lesson what
makes him so warm overlapping the
co-worker and constantly using feedback
tokens don't misinterpret these tokens
though go look up high what does it mean
yes not in the world of icy Chi another
u.s. business person let's say not Gary
is giving a Japanese subordinate advice
on running an ad campaign despite
repeating height the employee does not
take or implement any of not Gary's
advice what well there were hints of
disagreement here but also so important
these tokens tell you I follow go on as
these researchers put it interrupting
Isaac II mean I listen but never
agreement or empathy now they used the
word back-channel a term coined in 1974
short messages a listener gives back to
a speaker English also has overlapping
back channels Japanese just does it more
like three times more and curiously
Mandarin
a lot less less than Korean where the
metaphor is instead beating the mutual
drum I like that one
English listeners tend to back channel
when it's time to take turns but like
Japanese Korean listeners were heard
back channeling between turns speakers
actually cued listeners to back channel
by raising pitch and drawing out sounds
so one reason it's impolite not to
interrupt in Japanese may come down to
this simple mechanism pitch analyzing a
bunch of messy conversations this paper
found that speakers were lowering their
pitch 110 milliseconds before back
channels low or maybe high pitch change
was a solid predictor better than the
meaning of the utterance better even
than weather speakers have finished
their thought so active listeners but
also active speakers inviting reactions
and building conversations together
dynamic Japanese speakers even use loops
a back back channel to respond to your
back channel signals that the floor is
now open for your turn
speakers prompting listeners prompting
speakers this is what reminded me of the
rhythms and interruptions of my training
my since I did give opinions all the
most okay when you did well Sol on when
you glimpsed hard to repeat perfection
but often I think the feedback was eyes
achieve that really meant keep going and
with you here supporting me that's
exactly what I plan to do animating
linguistic tales takes a while but my
hands are already busy with the next one
so stick around and subscribe for
language
[Music]